In this course, we explored how to use the Path Tracer in Unreal Engine 5.6
to achieve high fidelity cinematic quality visuals.
We began with an introduction to Path Tracer, what it is, why it matters,
and how it delivers physically accurate lighting and reflections with minimal setup.
We also covered how it integrates seamlessly with Sequencer and Movie Render Queue,
and how to enable it in both project settings and your viewport.
Next, we walked through Path Tracer's configuration,
adjusting parameters through post-processing volumes and console variables,
tuning lighting components, and resolving translucency and depth of field issues
using Reference Depth of Field.
We explored modified material features including support for eye and hair shaders,
controlling glass absorption, leveraging energy conservation,
and using the Path Tracing Quality Switch Replace node
to define fallback materials for non-path traced scenes.
Then we broke down material setup and creation,
showing how to build realistic materials like thin glass using thin translucent shading,
or light absorption materials using the Absorption Medium Output node.
We also demonstrated how to create a debug material with the Path Tracing Ray Type Switch node
to visualize per-ray type behavior for camera, shadow, indirect view, specular, and volumetric.
You learned how to work with post-processing material buffers to access raw path traced data,
including radiance, denoise radiance, albedo, normal, and variance,
which is useful for composing, grading, and debugging.
We reviewed methods to reduce artifacts such as noise and fireflies using sample control,
denoising tools like Intel's Open Image Denoiser, and other quality-focused CVAR adjustments.
We also examined caustic lighting, comparing refractive and approximate caustics,
and how to find two results using r.pathtracing.approximate caustics,
and related console commands.
And finally, we discussed Skylight best practices, enabling real-time capture,
increasing capture resolution, and setting Is Sky Flag on sky geometry,
and disabling shadow casting to prevent over-occlusion.
We wrapped up with pro tips for controlling denoisers, working with heterogeneous volumes,
and optimizing performance while maintaining photo accuracy.
By now you should have all the tools and understanding to push your path tracer renders further,
delivering physically accurate production-ready visuals inside Unreal Engine 5.6.